people should realize we're in a new era
the idea of you're a nice little green
grass getting lots of water every day
that could be a thing of the past
they're tearing down kitty forts in Utah
banning fast food in Idaho that this
month we return once again to California
to highlight the most obnoxious finger
wagger Governor Jerry Brown issued a
statewide mandate statewide mandate for
reductions in water use by a lot listen
up you bad boys and girls Governor Brown
says your water Hungary won't be
tolerated behold his unprecedented
executive order where scofflaws could
face $500 day fines and court action to
boot it's gonna affect golf courses
people's lawns and people who wash their
cars or shower more than the governor
wants them to but what won't be affected
as much is the agriculture industry
which guzzles about 80% of the state's
water in fact growing just one crop
almonds uses more water than all the
homes and businesses in LA and San
Francisco combined as Californians we
have to pull together and save water in
every way we can
unless you're well connected Sacramento
politicians keep water artificially
cheap for their pals in the AG industry
and Sacramento residents pay a flat rate
regardless of how much water they use
but brown and company never miss an
opportunity to scroll the rest of us for
hosing down our Hondas we're standing on
dry grass and we should be standing in
five feet of snow no snow in a spot
where they're supposed to be lots of
snow that's right governor nature gives
us droughts but politicians make water
shortages you and your crew have been
making them for decades follow the show
on Twitter submit your nanny nominees
special thanks to Ross and check back
next month for more examples of
busybodies minding your own business